we've been thinking about the square
roots of complex numbers recently
and in order to understand what those
square roots are and how they fit onto
the complex plane we have to move from
thinking about them just as algebraic
objects or arithmetic objects that you
know you just square it and then the
coefficients just turn out nicely
we need to move to thinking about them
as visual objects and understand them
geometrically now we've already seen a
bit of this before
when we noticed that you can solve for
the square roots of complex number not
just in rectangular form but also in
exponential form or polar form by
extension
but in exponential form it's really nice
and neat you get some visual intuition
from that and what we're going to do is
push
on that and expand that intuition with
this question so
let x plus iy squared equal a
plus i b then we have x squared whoops
daisy
x squared minus y squared equals a and
2xy equals
b so let's just remember where that
comes from
when you take excuse me if you take this
guy here and just expand
the left hand side what you'll get is x
squared plus 2 i x y
and then you're going to get plus i
squared y squared but i squared is just
minus 1 right so you get minus y squared
all of that is what you get from
expanding the left hand side
but from the right hand side you get
this now
what you should see here is that the x
squared minus y squared
is the real component there are no eyes
attached to it so x squared minus y
squared the real component on the left
hand side must be equivalent to the
real component on the right hand side
and that's that's what's written here so
this
is from the real whereas the
2i x y that's imaginary just like i b
is imaginary so when you compare the
imaginary parts 2 times x times y
that equals b so this is what we get
from the
imaginary side over here so that's how
you get these two
simultaneous equations now we've been
used to solving those simultaneous
equations just by crunching the algebra
right by doing some substitution
bit of rearrangement and then your
solutions um arise from these equations
but what this question is asking us to
do is to think about them graphically
you can see it says
for the moment assume that both a and b
are positive then sketch the graphs
of these two equations on the same
number plane
now we we haven't been sketching graphs
all that recently
on a cartesian plane certainly but uh we
need to call back all that knowledge and
skill to be able to handle
these two guys here okay so what we're
going to have a look at is trying to
understand the graphs of these
on the same number plane and see what
conclusions we can draw from this okay
so the first one which we got from the
real components of the left hand right
hand side
is x squared minus y squared equals a
we're going to
see what that looks like so if you go to
some graphing software
you'll be able to put together a graph
of this and i'm appealing to this right
away
because in the old version of the
extension 2 course
there was a topic called conics which
was short for conic
sections conic as it comes from a cone
because there's a wonderful series of
shapes which seem all disconnected
that we've learned about in mathematics
already circles
ellipses parabolas and the shape you're
about to see they're all connected
by their relationship to the cone now
let me try and explain what's going on
i'm going to graph the equation that
they suggested to us before
x squared and then i think they said
minus y squared and that's going to be
equal to
a now you can see i've got a set to
equal one for
uh for a moment just before i type in
one i want you to have a think maybe
pause the video
and um try and contemplate this if
you've never seen an equation like this
before
what shape would you predict to emerge
from it
um you know you know what y equals x
squared looks like that's a parabola
you know what x squared plus y squared
equals a constant you know what that is
that's a that's a circle right
so what happens when you get x squared
minus
y squared what kind of shape would
emerge from that
like i said i hope you spend some time
to have to think about before
you now play and see what's going to go
on when i put in it's equal to
a watch what shape emerges
what is this uh well it's very strange
shape for starters
it's not a function if you think back to
earlier uh in year 11
when we're looking at functions we said
that if you put in one input and x value
you should get one
output one y value if i put in something
like x
equals two in fact i'll just quickly
draw x equals two x equals two
there's a single x value and it does not
have just one y value one output it's
got two of them
looks like plus or minus a square root
of three okay um so
this is not a function it is what we
call what we classify a relation
um but what other kind of way do you
have to describe this shape let's get
rid of this we don't need anymore
this actually is a shape that's
surprisingly familiar you just haven't
looked at it in this orientation
before so if i just go back to where i
was drawing
here's one i prepared earlier if you
have a look at
oh no i'm partially deleting that's not
what i want to do if you have a look at
this shape
here oh go away i'm highlighting why am
i highlighting there we go
there's my highlighting by accident
there's the shape which we just got out
of uh
doing this graph what i'm going to do is
something a bit unusual i'm going to
take this shape
and i'm going to rotate it and i hope
that once i've done the rotation it will
look a little more familiar
so let me spin this around and i'm going
to spin it exactly
45 degrees that looks
pretty alright to me let's move that
down the page a little bit
if it's still not looking obvious let me
put in
an extra line or two i'm going to put
one
vertically through let's get this
straight there we go
vertically through there and i'm going
to match it with one horizontally
through here ah that's pretty close
i'm reasonably satisfied with that all
right when you have a look at this
does this look like a familiar shape
this is of course
the hyperbola even though from the
original you saw
um we had to rotate this thing through
45 degrees or pi on four
radians so this is the same shape but
it's looked at at a different
orientation this is still a hyperbola so
it's just a different kind of hyperbola
than you've dealt with like i said
it used to be dealt with in the old
course so you can have a look at there
i've got videos on this if you're
curious
now what they then say is to investigate
what happens
when you plot this on the same graph as
the other
equation that we got simultaneously x
squared minus y squared equals a that's
what happens when you
compare the real components on the left
and right hand side the other equation
was 2 x y is equal to
b and just like a b is something which
can change in value but it's a constant
of some kind so
i'm going to put in the b now i'm not
hesitating on this one because
this is a shape you are much more
familiar with this is just the regular
hyperbola right
um the one that you're used to dealing
with which has kind of this horizontal
vertical thing
by the way this is not just any
hyperbola this is called the rectangular
hyperbola because the two asymptotes
which in this case are the x and y axes
the the two asymptotes are at right
angles and that's actually what
rectangular means
rect just means right and angle means
angle so rectangular means right angled
that's why rectangles are called
rectangles all the angles are 90 degrees
so this is the rectangular hyperbola
that you're used to dealing with like y
equals 1 over x
but this has you know this is not just 1
over x this might be something else
over x because of the b and the 2 which
change the coefficients
now the question pushes further on this
it doesn't just say graph these right
it says think about this a little
further it says what feature of your
sketch
indicates that there are two square
roots of a
plus i b all right we need to pedal back
for a moment and think about what's
going on here
this equation here will tell us that x
plus iy
whatever particular x and whatever
particular y those are
if you square them they'll give you a
plus ib in other words
x plus iy whatever values of x and y
that satisfy this
those will be the square roots now we've
already worked with square roots a
little bit before so we know that every
complex number
has two square roots in fact every
number has two
square roots but how can we draw that
conclusion from
our our sort of graph that we've got
here well it comes back to
what we did algebraically when we
arrived at these two solutions and when
we proceeded from there what did we do
at this point
if you got like x squared plus y minus y
squared equals one and you've got two xy
equals whatever other value four or five
or something like that what did you do
from there
well you solved simultaneously didn't
you you were trying to find
some values of x and y that would
exist for both of these two solutions
sorry both of these two equations at the
same time
that's what solving simultaneously means
find a solution that simultaneously
makes sense or satisfies both equations
now when you are solving simultaneously
what you're really finding like if i
told you
here's an equation y equals x and then
here's another equation
y equals x squared if i asked you to
solve these
simultaneously what you would be finding
is an x
and a y which work for both equations
which is to say
an x and a y that's a pair of
coordinates that sit on both graphs
at the same time what we're finding are
points of intersection so i want you to
have a look at this right
the points of intersection between this
green and blue graph
you can actually see by plotting on here
and here these are the particular points
of intersection between them
and because if we move a around you can
see i'm going to keep it positive
because
a and b they initially want us to
restrict it to positive
if i move a you can see it changes the
shape of my hyperbola i
change its kind of scale or it's sort of
stretchiness right
but every time you like no matter how
far you move i mean my
mind max is out of 10 but you could make
it anything you like it's going to keep
on moving
outwards and it will always have these
two
points of intersection between the green
and the red graphs no matter which way
you know however far you change these
numbers you're still going to get those
points of intersection
right